the premier award show and digital
achievement
thank you so much streamys for inviting
me this year because last year I was
writing this platonic date and thank you
so much for this award that they
wouldn't miss before
I know anything the success of sharknado
is that the people got so excited so it
became such a successful John about the
science I'm totally not one of them I
mean I have no business watching back to
school makeup tutorials but yet I find
myself kind of sucked in Perales I think
we all are but the truth is it's not
only about the smoky eye or the fuller
lips from the contouring secrets it's
really about their mesmerizing
personalities that keep us glued to
their videos here are the Streamy Award
nominees for beauty program here are the
Streamy Award nominees for beauty
program
guys can't tell you trying to be
sentimental for a minute
just standing on the first youtubers
anyone remember oh my gosh playlist yes
when I saw you was like hi I'm Hannah
and then you were like I'm just dating
and everybody was like this I just seen
tough guys like I'm so ignorant I'm here
you are over three weeks from using this
is so amazing
thanks dude and a head of book yeah and
we also need to make a smoothie when we
do it we have to it's honestly my
friends are all out there they're the
hardest working people I know and to see
them get acknowledgement for
a shredder the work that they do is just
like the coolest thing in the world so
that's what this drink is all about yeah
thank you
we have lovely viewers here